College in theory and in practice in a
few places still in America is a good
thing
yeah
can be a good thing but not everything
is for everyone
the libs always talk about diversity and
how great diversity is they greatly
overstate the importance and benefits of
diversity but humanity is somewhat
diverse and not everything is for
everyone so if you send people who ought
not go to college to college that is
going to harm them and make the college
experience worse for everybody else
because it's inevitably going to lead to
a lowering of Standards it's going to
lead to a flooding of the administrative
class with new babysitters basically to
modify students who can't hack it in
college and it's going to raise costs
it's going to create all sorts of
problems